الادوات الكرسنهم الاواني ديال المطبخ
بنحاول ان نرسم كذلك طفل صغير
كره القدم
[موسيقى]
ادري خالي كان رسم ثانويه واحد الفيديو
يخليك تستغرق الوقت كثير اذكار الصباح
[موسيقى]
وايضا كارتون جداريه ضخمه في الشارع يعني
نزلوا على الطلب بعد الجماهير
ما اعطاني واحد فكره انني مش نرسم كره
القدم كاس الرسم ثم كنعرف ان الكره دائريه
ما فيهاش واحد الزاويه اللي تقدر انكسر
صندل الفيزاج ديال الوجه
[موسيقى]
المنتخب المغربي
[تصفيق]
اصعب لاعب برشلونه
[موسيقى]
في الموقع انستغرام
الرسم السعرادي هو يعني قليل في العالم
العربي دابا عن طريق سوشيال خليهم يشوفوه
[موسيقى]
من اصعب اللي تابلت لي كرتون
جوجو في اللوحه شوفوا هذا اللاعب ديالي
يوسف
[موسيقى]
راس السنه
بغيت نخليه واحد في كاس العالم
[موسيقى]